that story is awesome indeed
thank you for sharing jenny
ann was getting a little chummy
when people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome lester
[Music]
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
i want you to come back well i don't
want to come back
the end
i was talking to andy about you
and he made me realize that i need you
back at work what did he say
don't recall fine i'll come back
good
okay i'm leaving
bye zuzu
bye
duke silver
my mom has all your albums
i recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
i love food and stuff
it's where i buy all of my food
and most of my stuff
hey can i get these
how much are there
two bucks a piece
good deal
anything else
nope
just the crows and the beef
i had it in a safe place and then i
moved it to protect it and i don't
remember where i see don't be mad ron
she hid it too good
then she left a string of clues
it's an impossible puzzle and i love
puzzles a minimal unhelpful note these
appear to be human teeth and what is
this twilight new moon it's a movie but
i've never seen it it's like about lame
werewolves and vampires and stuff donna
likes those things dollars to donuts
this points us her way finally a
scavenger hunt worthy of my time
onward
we have a wonderfully small number of
clues one is this ticket did you see
this movie about vampires and such new
moon yeah i saw it with april she was so
hopped up on painkillers from getting
her wisdom teeth out i convinced you to
see it with me the teeth they're yours
you were super out of it you kept
yelling team voldemort at the screen and
we were kicked out i was furious
you only get to see the second twilight
film for the seventh time once do you
remember anything about a key or april
doing anything unusual that day she did
make a stop by the shoeshine stand
before we left because she wanted to
drop something off for andy she had a
real bad crush on him oh
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still to the
shoeshine stand
so much has changed around here uh i
just wanted to remember the good old
days when a shoe shine was two bits and
there were no mexicans in the music
business if you don't mind councilman
milton we just need to search this stand
yes
found it
hi andy i hate people but you are okay
it's weird woof woof april my god baby
we're so into me that's hilarious
that's it it's a dead end no more clues
see me in my office
so i guess we are celebrating that
you trusted me and i let you down
great i changed my house locks every 16
days that key has been useless since the
second tuesday after i gave it to you
what matters is that i trust you
and admire you as a person
i will be sorry to see you leave this
town for many reasons
not the least of which is that you
created a puzzle that even i couldn't
solve
and boy oh boy
did you love andy
woof woof
it really is embarrassing oh my god i
totally know where the key is
how'd you remember
woof
barf why here
because this tree reminds me of you it's
strong and quiet
and always here when you need it
or whatever
i have always felt a certain kinship
with april and this is proof that i was
correct
not the nice things she said about me
the fact that i buried a large amount of
gold under that same tree years
ago
i have since moved it
or have i
or was i lying the whole time
or was i lying about lying
or was there never any gold to begin
with
or
do you live here
april
yeah
do you live here
no
catch
yeah i thought so
i went home but i had this strange
feeling that there was something wrong
with you so i came back
it's just a minor medical issue
aids
no i'm safe
blindness
no is it like a parasite or a virus or
something you get from a bee
i have a hernia do you have syphilis i
said it's a hernia i know
it's possible to have two things
do you need a ride to the hospital
yes please
okay
but i rode my bike here so i have to go
home and get my dad's station wagon
thank you
bye
you're still here yeah
i just wanted to see if you could tell
are you still
here yo
i had to wait till my dad fell asleep so
i could steal his keys
you ready
i was born ready
i'm ron swanson
easy
careful
careful
i didn't do anything for my office it's
okay i took care of it i made a
marshmallow ron swanson oh
my gosh his arms are crossed because
he's mad at all the other marshmallow
workers for annoying him
you like it
it's fine
everything okay
um
no
you ready
yeah
and when you haven't done no geez ron
for god's sake she's an adult now she
should know how to responsibly handle
and discharge your weapon
that there is a sig sauer 22 caliber
mosquito manufactured in switzerland for
their [ __ ] police force this two-toned
lightweight model is perfect for a
skinny little thing like you
gee thanks ron
i will hold on to this for you until we
get you licensed up
and then i'll take you for some target
practice
goody
yeah i do feel a little guilty
i'm re-gifting
you